hmm so I took that Pottermore quiz
yesterday I got sorted into Slytherin
what's wrong with Slytherin people
assume being sorted into Slytherin is a
bad thing
you know it's not a single witch or
wizard who went bad that wasn't in
Slytherin eh that's not true and B I'm a
Slytherin really they consider them
silva Sh power-hungry and evils you're
not evil
exactly I'm not in truth there's a lot
more to slytherins than just being one
of the bad guys
slytherins are often perceived as being
power-hungry yeah I'm gonna be out of
the office next week for for a little
vacation but if someone could take over
in the meantime and it's true they like
to be in control I'll do it it's not
always for reasons you'd expect all
right now that I'm in charge everyone
can bring their dog to the office it's
true slytherins can get a little
competitive sometimes okay
very competitive yes they're not exactly
the easiest people to make friends with
hey I'm Chantal I'm new here
cool welcome that doesn't mean they're
horrible people they just prefer to have
a small group of tightly knit friends
compared to a large group of mediocre
one and then I said which please yeah
and if anyone messes with part of their
inner circle hey what's up you're ready
for a bad person better watch out
smarter son if a Slytherin is ever
looking particularly evil it's usually
for a good reason so I'm sure you're all
curious who the employee of the month is
Zane was again our top performer in
terms of numbers but we're actually
gonna give it to Kenny for his moral
fiber really then Dumbledore's a [ __ ]
ass hat if you've been sorted into
Slytherin don't let that get you down
remember it could always be worse you
could have been a Hufflepuff I found
some cookies if anyone wants a look I
got surprised by your teeth
you